[Musique]
en 2007 rappelez-vous le mont mégantic
brillait en devenant la première réserve
internationale de ciel étoilé au monde
l'idée a fait du chemin quinze ans plus
tard on s'attelle au projet de rallumer
les étoiles dans la nuit de sherbrooke
une ville illuminé le soir à quelque
chose d'un peu magique
le problème c'est que plus il ya
d'éclairage qui pointe vers le ciel
moins on a de chance de voir des étoiles
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont jamais vu la
voie lactée a lancé on peut amener à
faire un éclairage qui permettent aux
soyez de reprendre contact avec le ciel
étoilé ce serait super et le plus
logique quand on veut créer une oasis de
celle étoilé en ville c'est de le faire
à partir d'une zone déjà sombre comme le
parc du mont bellevue en plein coeur de
sherbrooke
l'initiative revient à johan ruby et à
martin aubé tous deux professeurs au
cégep de sherbrooke
ont dit restaurer la voie lactée on veut
rendre la voie lactée puis pour faire ça
ce qu'il faut faire c'est d'agir sur les
éclairages qui sont soit de mauvaise
qualité ou trop trop intense et
évidemment on se concentre sur les
éclairages proche de l'endroit qu'on
veut protéger dans notre code mont
bellevue
pour identifier ses sources d'éclairage
problématique on consulte d'abord les
images satellitaires de sherbrooke ce
qu'on voit à l'écran c'est l'intensité
lumineuse émise par les lambada vers
l'espace dans qui a été capté par la
s'atténue on détermine ensuite avec plus
de précision d'où provient la pollution
lumineuse sur le mont bellevue donc une
fois qu'on a ça on peut aller cibler ces
territoires l'eau pour agir
préférentiellement à sedan saison là si
on veut faire un gain maximum
au niveau de la restauration du sel
ceylac fois les en superposant sur le
plan de la ville la position connue des
lampadaires publics on peut déduire que
l'éclairage limitrophes au parc
appartient à la ville à l'université et
à des résidences privées
la ville a décidé d'appuyer ce type de
projet là pour protéger le sait les
toilettes
[Musique]
la ville de sherbrooke a déjà un plan
d'éclairage plus respectueux du ciel
étoilé à cause de l'observatoire du mont
mégantic qui se trouve à proximité
hydro sherbrooke qui veillent à
l'entretien et à la mise à niveau
graduelle de l'éclairage public était
d'accord pour prioriser les lampadaires
situés à proximité du mont bellevue pour
savoir lesquels précisément on a mis des
étudiants du cégep de sherbrooke au
travail ils ont élaboré une base de
données détaillées sur l'éclairage
hauteur des lampadaires hauteur des
maisons une fois les données traitées à
l'aide de modèles mathématiques on peut
connaître la contribution de chaque
lampadaire à la pollution lumineuse sur
le mont bellevue on a calculé par
exemple dans notre corps à peu près 15
luminaires seulement à changer pour
débat et c'est la pollution de l'eau sde
à peu près 30% donc oui ça va très vite
et on y arrive avec un jet de lumière
plus doux diffuse et surtout vers le sol
sur le campus de l'université de
sherbrooke adossé au mont bellevue on
adopter les mêmes mesures au l'éclairage
de certains bâtiments
les grands principes pour contrer la
pollution lumineuse sont simples et
claires et le solde est don du ciel
choisir une couleur plus en brie
utiliser l'intensité nécessaire pas plus
éteindre la lumière quand elle n'est pas
utilisée des principes qui s'appliquent
aussi bien sûr à l'éclairage résidentiel
la dernière source et les éclairages
privée donc les petites lumières que
tout un chacun mais devant sa maison qui
est un problème parce qu'on a évalué que
ça représentait près de 50 % de la
pollution lumineuse
avec quelques étudiants johan ruby
s'attaque à convaincre les gens du
quartier ciblé à gagner des étoiles en
échange dans pool une porte à la fois
comment faire embarquer les gens dansent
un projet comme celui là on va leur
offrir 100 poules
par un équipe l'église étudiants l'idée
d'en faire un quartier modèle pour le
projet il l'éclairage est pas du tout
éblouissant pour les yeux c'est très
calme très reposant des rues qui vont
passer du blanc éclatant et bleutés au
jaune ambré l'alcool sherbrooke comme
toutes les villes au québec dont une
surabondance de couleur bleue dans notre
éclairage
le problème avec la lumière bleue c'est
qu'elle diffuse très efficacement dans
l'atmosphère
[Musique]
les ampoules qu'ils ont offerte pour les
résidences privées en contiennent très
peu il défi a été de les trouver nous
enfin d'avec une compagnie d'éclairage
us et à sherbrooke in the d'image peut
regarder du côté de l'asie et les faire
fabriquer leurs spécifications
1500 cas faible intensité 5 et 7 watts
et plus de bleu
contrairement à une ampoule blanche qui
en contient autour de 37% leurs ampoules
en contient autour de 3%
on sent qu'on fait partie d'un
changement parce que la lumière est l'e
book plus chaudes
[Musique]
depuis peu il mesure la brillance du
ciel partir d'un appareil installé dans
le parc
éventuellement elles pourront estimer à
quel point le ciel ce sera assombri au
dessus du mont bellevue
on a déjà fait des modélisations donc un
une étude théorique si on veut pour
savoir qu'est ce qu'on pouvait gagner
sont aussi qu'on peut gagner à peu près
50% de qualité de ces étoiles est
évidemment le ciel ne sera jamais aussi
étoiles etc à l'observatoire du mont
mégantic
on est en ville après tout mais déjà
tendre à éclairer le sol plutôt que le
ciel ne prive personne de lumière il ya
aussi un problème assez important au
niveau des concessionnaires automobiles
des des stations service par exemple qui
est même beaucoup de lumière ils ne sont
pas les seuls pensez aux éclairages
puissant qu'on voit de loin ceux des
terrains de jeu ben on peut pas empêcher
les gens faire des sports de s'apprendre
l'éclairage par contre on demande à
toutes les opérateurs de ces éclairages
la d'éteindre l'éclairage au maximum
trente minutes après la fin des
activités
[Musique]
pour ce qui est de la croix ou sommet du
mont bellevue la ville a accepté de
réduire de 75% son intensité lumineuse
durant la nuit ont beau s'en tire comme
étant très de retrouver les étoiles une
pré l'autre parce que tranquillement les
tous les changements d'éclairage qu'on
fait mais on va chercher les étoiles
l'une après l'autre je pense que la
valeur d'un ciel étoilé en ville c'est
inestimable en fait c'est un peu comme
si on posait la question c'est quoi la
valeur de pouvoir voir des fleurs dans
la ville s'ils avaient une pollution qui
nous cache les flamands seraient pas
contents c'est la même chose pour les
étoiles mais c'est la nuit et retrouver
les nuits d'une certaine manière ce
serait aussi une façon de retrouver la
vie quelle qu'elle soit
[Musique]